Y, por desgracia, las mujeres han tenido menos.
Y se nos considera menos.
Y así mi atención, ¿a dónde debía ir?
Era solo... simplemente tienes que hacerlo.
Y aprender a encararte a ti misma, oír tu propia voz.
Oyes las mismas palabras todo el tiempo,
y tengo mucha suerte porque tengo una educación.
Y creo que si puedes verlo puedes llegar a serlo,
si puedes verlo, puedes lograrlo.
Si ves a Pat, ves otros líderes,
ves a esos ídolos, te ves ti misma,
porque todo el mundo,
cada uno de nosotros,
puede hacer algo extraordinario.
Cada persona.
MP: Y tu historia, Billie, ha inspirado a muchas mujeres en todas partes.
Ahora, con la Iniciativa de Liderazgo Billie Jean King,
estás actuando por una causa aún mayor.
Porque algo que escuchamos mucho es que las mujeres están levantando su voz,
trabajando para encontrar su camino en las posiciones de liderazgo.
Pero de lo que hablas es aún más grande que eso.
Es un liderazgo integrador.
Esta es una generación que ha crecido pensando de modo más inclusivo
BJK: ¿No es genial? ¡Mira la tecnología!
Es increíble cómo nos conecta a todos. Se trata de la conexión.
Es simplemente increíble lo que hace posible.
Pero la Iniciativa de Liderazgo King Billie Jean
es mucho de la fuerza de trabajo, de cómo tratar de cambiarla,
que la gente puede ir a trabajar y ser sus auténticos yos.
Dado que la mayoría de nosotros tenemos dos trabajos:
Uno, para adaptarse... Te daré un ejemplo perfecto.
Una mujer afroamericana se levanta una hora antes de ir a trabajar,
se arregla el pelo en el baño,
va al baño, probablemente, cuatro, cinco, seis veces al día
para arreglarse pelo, para asegurarse de que encaja.
Así, ella tiene 2 empleos.
Ella tiene este otro trabajo, sea lo que sea,
pero también tratar de encajar.
O este pobre hombre que logró su diploma,
--fue a la Universidad de Michigan,
pero nunca habló de su pobreza de joven, nunca--
simplemente no lo mencionó.
Se aseguró de que vieran que era bien educado.
Y luego ves a un chico gay que está en la NFL
--lo que significa el fútbol americano para todos Uds.
algo grande, muy machista--
y hablaba sobre fútbol todo el tiempo,
porque era gay y no quería que nadie lo supiera.
Y así a así.
Así que mi deseo para todos es puedan ser su auténtico yo 24/7,
eso sería lo máximo.
Y nos sorprendemos, quiero decir, me sorprendo yo misma.
Incluso siendo gay me sorprendo a mí misma
(¡huy!)
estando algo incómoda en mis entrañas,
sintiéndome no totalmente cómoda en mi propia piel.
Por eso, creo que hay que preguntarse,
quiero que la gente sea ella misma, lo que sea, pero que lo sea.
MP: La primera investigación de la Iniciativa de Liderazgo mostró que
que en estos ejemplos que acabas de usar,
muchos tenemos el problema de ser auténticos.
Pero lo que se ve en esta generación del milenio,
que se han beneficiado de toda esta igualdad de oportunidades,
quizá no iguales, pero existen en todo lugar.
BJK: Primero, soy muy afortunada.
Estar asociada con Teneo, una empresa estratégica que es increíble,
es realmente la razón para poder hacer esto.
Dos veces en mi vida
realmente he tenido hombres con poder apoyándome.
En los viejos tiempos con Philip Morris con Virginia Slims,
y esta es la segunda vez en toda mi vida.
Y ahora Deloitte.
Lo único que quería eran datos, hechos.
Así Deloitte envió una encuesta,
y más de 4000 personas la han respondido,
y seguimos en el lugar de trabajo.
¿Y qué sienten los milenio?
Sienten mucho, pero lo que es tan fantástico es...
nuestra generación pensaba: "Obtendremos representación".
Así que si vas a una sala, ves a todos representados.
Ya no es lo suficientemente bueno, aunque sea bueno.
La generación milenio es fantástica; quiere conexión, compromiso.
Solo quieren que nos digan lo que sientes y piensas,
y encontrar una solución.
Pueden resolver problemas,
y por supuesto, se tiene la información al alcance,
en comparación a cuando yo era pequeña.
PM: ¿Qué mostró la investigación sobre esta generación?
¿Van a marcar una diferencia?
¿Crearán un mundo en que haya realmente una fuerza de trabajo inclusiva?
BJK: Bueno, en 2025, el 75 % de la fuerza laboral mundial
será de la generación milenio.
Creo que ayudarán a resolver problemas.
Creo que tienen los medios para hacerlo.
Sé que les importa mucho.
Tienen grandes ideas y pueden hacer que se logren grandes cosas.
Quiero quedarme en el ahora con los jóvenes,
no quiero estar detrás.
(Risas)
PM: ¡No creo que haya oportunidad!
Pero lo que descubriste sobre la generación milenio
no es realmente la experiencia que mucha gente tiene con la generación del milenio.
BJK: No, bueno, si queremos hablar... OK, he hecho mi pequeña mini-encuesta.
He estado hablando con los Boomers, que son sus jefes, y me voy,
"¿Qué piensa Ud. acerca de los milenio?".
Y estoy bastante emocionada, como si fuera bueno,
y ponen esta cara
(Risas)
"Oh, la generación 'yo'?".
Yo digo: "¿De verdad lo crees?
Porque yo creo que se preocupan por el medio ambiente
y todas estas cosas".
Y siguen, "Oh, Billie, no pueden concentrarse".
(Risas)
Ellos realmente han demostrado
que el enfoque promedio de un joven de 18 años es de 37 segundos.
(Risas)
No pueden concentrarse.
Y no les importa.
Acabo de escuchar una historia la otra noche:
una mujer es dueña de una galería y tiene estos trabajadores.
Recibe un texto de una de las trabajadoras,
como una interna, que acaba de comenzar:
"Oh, por cierto, voy a llegar tarde porque estoy en la peluquería".
(Risas)
Así que ella llega, y este jefe dice,
"¿Que tal todo?".
Y dice: "Oh, es tarde, lo siento, ¿cómo va todo?".
Ella dice: "Bueno, ¿adivina qué? Te vas, estas despedida".
Ella dice: "Bien".
(Risas)
¡No hay problema!
PM: Billie, esa historia...
Lo sé, eso es lo que asusta a los del "baby boom".
Digo, que creo que es bueno compartir.
(Risas)
De verdad es bueno compartir,
porque somos nuestro auténtico yo y lo que sentimos,
así que tenemos que tomar las dos cosas.
Pero tengo gran fe, porque...
si has estado en deporte como yo,
cada generación es mejor.
Es un hecho.
Con la Fundación Deportiva de Mujeres en defensa del Título IX todavía,
intentamos mantener la protección de la ley,
porque está en una posición débil siempre,
así que realmente preocupa,
y hacemos mucha investigación.
Es muy importante para nosotros.
Y lo quiero oír de la gente.
Pero realmente tenemos que proteger el Título IX que representa a todos.
Y oyeron al Presidente Carter hablar de cómo el Título IX está protegido.
Y sabes que cada demanda
que las niñas, al menos en el deporte, han ido en contra
--cualesquiera que sean las instituciones--
¿ha ganado?
Título IX está ahí para protegernos.
Y es increíble.
Pero todavía hay que ganar los corazones y las mentes,
que corazones y mentes coincidan con la legislación es grande.
PM: ¿Qué te hace levantar todas las mañanas?
¿Qué te mantiene motivada en tu trabajo,
sostener la lucha por la igualdad, extendiéndola,
explorando nuevas áreas, encontrando nuevas maneras...?
BJK: Siempre volvía locos a mis padres porque siempre era muy curiosa.
Estoy muy motivada.
Mi hermano menor era jugador de las Grandes Ligas.
A mis pobres padres no les importaba si éramos buenos.
(Risas)
Y los volvimos locos porque insistíamos,
presionábamos por querer ser los mejores.
Y creo que es por lo que estoy hoy en las charlas de TED.
Creo que al escuchar a estas mujeres diferentes,
escuchar a diferentes personas,
escuchar al presidente Carter de 90 años, por cierto,
y esas cifras que mostró que yo nunca...
Me tengo que ir,
"Disculpe, espere un minuto, necesito una lista de estas cifras".
Es la caña, quiero decir, eso es increíble, lo siento.
MP: Es un hombre increíble.
(Aplausos)
BJK: Y tendrán a la presidenta Mary Robinson,
quien es expresidenta.
¡Gracias, irlandeses! ¡62 %! ¡LGBTI! ¡Sí!
(Aplausos)
El congreso votará en junio el matrimonio entre personas del mismo sexo,
son cosas que para algunas personas es muy difícil de escuchar.
Pero recuerden, cada uno de nosotros es un individuo,
un ser humano con un corazón que late,
que se preocupa y quiere vivir su vida auténtica.
No tienen que estar de acuerdo con nadie,
pero todos deben tener oportunidad.
Creo que todos tenemos una obligación
de seguir avanzando la aguja, siempre.
Y esta gente ha sido muy inspiradora.
Todo el mundo importa.
Y cada uno es un factor de influencia.
Ud. que nos escucha en el mundo, además de la gente de aquí,
cada persona es un factor de influencia.
Nunca, nunca lo olviden. ¿De acuerdo?
Así que no vuelvan a renunciar a Uds. mismos.
PM: Billie, una gran inspiración para nosotros.
BJK: Gracias, Pat.
(Aplausos)
¡Gracias, TED!
¡Muchas gracias!